you hear their footsteps coming down the
halls or are those your own
can you even tell the difference you can
tell they're getting closer
and you can feel the hate the rage you
turn
shaking and finally see them standing
right in front of you
but in that moment you might as well be
looking into a mirror
and who knows perhaps you are you just
don't seem to remember having
so many reflections have you ever heard
the saying you
are your own worst enemy of course it
isn't usually meant literally
but what if it was what if you had to
fight a monster
that was you all of your flaws are
reflected back
at you your strengths your weaknesses
your deepest fears with no way to escape
except a battle to the death
either way you're not making it out
alive
it's just a matter of which version of
you survives
but this isn't a thought experiment no
according to the findings of the scp
foundation
it's very much a reality there is a
place where this nightmare comes to life
and it's known as scp-1919
scp-1919 is a hotel and converted
mansion built in the early 20th century
from the outside it looks pretty much
like it did when it was first built
and it almost looks like a comfortable
place to stay
if you ignore the eastern side of the
building that has sunk partially into
the ground
the inside however is a different story
where it's clear the ravages of time
have taken
their toll the floorboards and ceilings
are rotting
collapsing in on themselves and the
rooms are filled with debris
it's deadly enough to explore the hotel
for these reasons alone
but this is only the beginning of the
danger for a person
inside in order to determine just how
dangerous it is for either one person
or group to enter the structure the scp
foundation planned a series of research
expeditions into the abandoned building
led by foundation scientist dr lemkowitz
the first expedition
seemed relatively normal at least it did
at the start
a 39 year old caucasian d-class male
known as d7 was sent into the structure
with a camera
and a communication system guided
remotely by dr limkowitz
or dr al and another operative a former
head of the mtf tau 11
youth hostiles who is referred to in
this file only
as t11 when he arrived at the building
d7 was unable to get inside through the
front door
or windows after several minutes of
trial and error
he was finally able to get in through
the western entrance
dr l picked up a strange high-pitched
whistling noise upon d7's entrance into
the building
but it quickly faded away and was
disregarded by t11
d7 discovered a torn painting a portrait
of a young woman with
red hair next to the portrait shallow
scratches could be seen
in the wall the floor and parts of the
ceiling
suddenly d7 ducked into a hiding place
alarm
he and the other two operatives
listening to his audio feed could hear
heavy breathing
and it didn't belong to d7 dr l
recommended that d7 evacuate the
building at this sign of another entity
inside
but t11 overruled ordering him to
disregard that instruction and continue
his investigation
d7 was told to stay at a safe distance
from whatever was inside with him
and attempt to capture it on video d7
turned off his flashlight in order to
better hide
but t11 commanded that he turn it back
on whatever was caught in the beam of
light was difficult for the camera to
see
but it threw d7 into a panic and he
began to run in the opposite direction
when prompted to explain what he saw d7
simply said
it was me d7 ran through the dark
panting with fear
and exertion unable to see where his
feet were landing
he tripped over something and came
crashing onto the ground
dropping the video camera this allowed
the observing officers to finally see
what d7 was so frightened by
and it became clear just why d7 was so
terrified a man identical looking to d7
approached from the end of the hallway
making its way towards the real d7 it
was followed by another man who also
resembled d7
and another all running toward the
original they all looked
exactly like him with a few notable
differences
they were dressed in the same uniform
with the same build and the same
features
but each had something slightly off
about him one was missing eyelids
another had malformed hands and the
third had its lips fused together into a
fleshy mass beneath its nose
dr l moved to cut the camera feed but
t11 demanded that it be kept running
d7 couldn't be seen by the camera but
the microphone picked up the sounds of
flesh and cloth being torn
along with pained panic screams as the
duplicates set
upon him after a moment the screaming
stopped
two hours later the camera was broken
and the expedition brought to a
troubling
end this was the foundation's first
glimpse at the creatures
inside of scp-1919 and it was not
pretty it did however allow them to
begin understanding the nature of the
building
and what happens when a person goes
inside it appears that when a human
enters the hotel
several humanoid creatures manifest
throughout the building these creatures
look like this subject
and are equipped with the same clothing
or items that the subject brought inside
with them
though they are nearly mirror images of
the subject they are always slightly
warped in a variety of ways
these have included changes to limb and
digit length
joint mobility sealed nostrils lengthen
jaws hanging loose and limp
missing eyelids and lips that are fused
together
these creatures are highly aggressive
towards the structure of the building
itself
as well as to the subject that they
resemble they do not
however attack each other they appear to
operate with a hive mind
exhibiting swarm intelligence like that
of an ant colony
once they have been spawned by the
entrance of a new person they will not
stop until said person either escapes
the building
or is killed after the unfortunate end
to the expedition the foundation prepped
for a second trip inside
this time three men were sent in with dr
l's guidance
known as d3 d4 and d9
video cameras were sewn into their
clothes to leave their hands free and
help avoid some of the issues that came
up during the first expedition
this small team was sent in with the
orders to terminate the remaining copies
of d7
and further examine the hotel's interior
upon
opening the door to the building they
were immediately attacked by one of d7's
copies
which d9 was able to quickly dispatch by
firing his weapon at its head
next after a great deal of reluctance
the three men
entered the building where they spotted
something unusual inside
dr al was horrified when the camera feed
revealed 17
discarded video cameras spread across
the floor
they didn't have much time to react to
this new discovery however
because two doubles one mirroring d7 and
another mirroring d9
emerged from the wall and began to
attack dr al
ordered the team to take shelter then
called the team of guards outside of the
hotel's perimeter
they were ordered to begin an immediate
full perimeter lockdown
preventing the doubles from leaving the
hotel d3
d4 and d9 attempted to make their way to
a safe corner of the building
but found themselves met with a
murderous double at every turn
at this point dr al began to hear an
unusual sound over the microphone feed
a high-pitched wine like that of a
dentist drill the operatives on the
ground couldn't hear a thing
but on dr l's end it was deafening as
the team proceeded deeper into the hotel
they became overcome with a strange
feeling of foreboding
dr al ordered them to turn on their
flashlights but they refused and begged
dr l to keep quiet
when prompted to explain d9 said she can
hear you
the operatives stopped responding but
their camera feeds caught a faint
glowing white light coming from beneath
the door
the door opened and the light flooded
the camera making the images it captured
hard to decipher
just a few frames of a quick moving
female silhouette were captured before
the cameras cut to static
the bodies of d3 d4 and d9 were never
recovered
nor were their cameras a third
expedition was also sent into scp-1919
but very little is known about what
occurred during it the video transcript
is highly classified
and only those present for its events or
approved to research
scp-1919 have access to it
an update to the scp-1919 file following
expedition 3 though
indicates that new information was
revealed about the hotel
during the excursion according to the
file update
there is some kind of being at the
center of the location
which is causing all of the other
creatures the doubles to appear
the only information available about
this being is the use of the word
her in the official foundation log about
scp-1919
this seems to match up with the last
moments of the operatives in expedition
2
when they told dr l that she can hear
you
and the few frames of a female figure
that were captured by their cameras
nothing else is known that has been made
available to anyone outside a very
select few
only the original report exists and all
other copies of it have been destroyed
the foundation has undertaken special
containment procedures to make sure that
none of the entities from inside the
hotel escape
whether they are the evil twins spawned
by humans entering the building
or the mysterious female being at the
center of the entire disturbing
phenomena
the foundation has classified scp-1919
as euclid
and a two-kilometer radius must be
maintained around
scp-1919 with all roads leading to the
building are blocked
or diverted so that no vehicles are able
to reach it
this perimeter is guarded by a set of at
least 40 armed and armored guards at any
given time
as it has been determined that the
devils spawn by 1919 are equipped with
whatever the human they are copying has
no one is allowed to enter the hotel
with body armor or
weapons of any kind anyone that
approaches the perimeter that is not a
part of an official expedition team will
be immediately terminated
no new expedition teams are allowed to
enter the building unless all doubles
from the previous expedition have been
exterminated in the event that they
cannot be exterminated
enough time must elapse between
expeditions that the previous devils
have starved to death
though they do not seem to feel hunger
the devils do
need to eat to survive and will die when
left alone
for long enough scp-1919 has been sealed
off from the rest of the world
so that no hapless civilians can wander
inside and find themselves torn to
pieces by
warped images of themselves but that
comfort turns cold when you realize that
the scp foundation
still does not understand what causes
these doubles to spawn
is it scientific supernatural or
something else
no one can be certain even more
inexplicable is the entity at the center
of
all of this an unknown female presence
capable of wrecking
frightening amounts of violence by
turning victims own
images against them what is the purpose
of these fun house mirror nightmares
who is she what is she and what does she
want
currently the doubles have shown no
interest in leaving the hotel
except to attack intruders and thanks to
that fact
as well as the reinforced perimeter
outside these copycats have not appeared
outside of the building
itself but what happens if they do
escape
or if the entity that controls them
decides to make her home
elsewhere there is no telling what could
happen if this dark power is allowed to
move beyond its current containment
are you prepared to fight a vision of
yourself twisted almost beyond
recognition
lunging after you with wide bulbous eyes
unnaturally long
arms and a distended jaw hanging down
below its neck
better hope you never have to find out
now go check out scp-001 the children
orborus cycle and scp-055-anti-meme
for more anomalous curiosities from the
scp
foundation